if you've ever watched Netflix's
original series sex education you'll
know that star Emma Mackey who plays
Maeve Bears a striking resemblance to
Barbie star and Academy Award nominee
Margot Robbie in fact it was the
resemblance that led to Mackie appearing
in the Barbie movie and an early version
of the film even acknowledged their
similar looks according to Robbie this
moment had to be cut from the final
product speaking to BuzzFeed during one
of their patented puppy interviews
Robbie said she plays one of the Barbies
in the movie pretty much because Greta
Gerwig and I thought it would be funny
Gerwig and Robbie actually came up with
a joke about the pair's similar
appearances but when all was said and
done it didn't land the way they thought
it would we were going to do this whole
joke about us looking similar and once
we got all dressed up as our Barbies we
were kind of like we don't actually look
that similar as it turned out the two
actors don't look all that similar when
one is rocking blonde hair and the
others are brunette so we didn't put
that joke in the movie but when people
come up to me and say I loved you in sex
education I just say thank you